take full responsibility for your life
except where you are and the
responsibility that you're going to take
yourself where you want to go we have
two primary choices in life we can
either accept conditions as they exist
or we can take the responsibility to
change them people want to exempt
themselves from taking responsibility
all they want to do is talk about the
problem every time you see them they'll
tell you their story over and over and
over and over again no no you want to
take responsibility for your life
I got me here I can get me out of this
and I'm getting out I'm not going to be
a volunteer victim so part of beginning
to get unstuck you've got to decide that
the behavior pattern that you have
adopted doesn't work for you you've got
to change your strategies and changing
your strategy means reinventing your
life recreating you and you have the
power to do that you can decide that
you're going to change that you're not
going to be a wimp you can decide that
you're going to stand up to life
you can decide that I'm going to live
each day as if it were my last you have
the power to make that decision
you can decide I'm going to work on
myself and develop myself I'm going to
empower me and all of these things that
are happening to me right now they're
just temporary inconveniences they're
not stronger than I am I'm in charge
here
overcoming the negative conversation
that inner dialog is going on all the
time even when you don't want it to be
there you've got to stand up inside
yourself sometimes and say shut up
[Music]
you've got to do this I was going to
give a presentation and this voice
inside of me saying you can't do this
you don't have everything it takes us
shut up I'm behind on my bills are you
telling me what I can't do I have got to
do it
you get scared sometimes your mind will
go blink on you
some people will you will allow to
unnerve you and you wonder what's wrong
with me that's why you've got to learn
to make a conscious deliberate
determined effort to stand up inside
yourself working on yourself watching
that inner dialogue it will determine
the quality of your life you just watch
- amazing clips from Les Brown take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]